actor director producer Peter Berg
Patriots Day is coming out
[Music]
that'll be select theaters December 31st
released everywhere January 13th yes I
you join Mark Wahlberg who's a producer
on the film as well yes and Mark's gonna
join us I think coming up and you got a
great cast here Kevin Bacon you got John
Goodman
you got mark you got Michelle Monaghan
JK Simmons is in there tremendous actor
JK yeah have you you haven't final edit
right it's already done we do it's done
we've been showing the movie two members
of the Boston community you know it's
about the Boston Marathon bombing and
about the hundred and fifty hours from
the time the bombs went off to the time
the last terrorist last brother was
caught in the boat and it's a pretty
intense look at how the the city of
Boston came together and face that
tragedy and and rose up and and fought
back and it's a film about fighting back
and it's a film about kind of the love
that that community showed for each
other it's it's the my favorite film
that I've ever made how cautious do you
have to be were you in making this and
the fact what was it too soon to be
making a movie about this well you know
I think um for me you know we heard that
when we were filming about three years
after the bomb had gone off and you know
obviously for so many people in Boston
those wounds were still fresh and people
hadn't finished their grieving process
but you know one of the the things that
that you know I think unfortunately I'll
have to to accept is that this is the
new world we live in you know these acts
of terrorism unfortunately are no longer
surprising you turn on the news you wake
up in the morning and you see that
something really Bad's happened it's
it's no longer the shock that it was
certainly not 11 or even during Boston
and one of the things I find amazing
about the community of Boston and we
spent so much time with the police and
the EMT guys and the firefighters and
the emergency room doctors and just the
citizens of that city you know is is
seeing how they survived it and you know
question that mark
and I find you know ourselves asking and
being asked of our children there's no
you know dad what what what is all this
mean well why are people doing this to
us and how do we how do we survive it
and I think what we saw in Boston was of
example the very best of humanity and
it's an example of how these these
barbaric acts may occur but we actually
can survive and at the end of the day
love beats hate and good beats evil and
at the end of the day I think we are
basically good people and are you
recreating this in the actual places no
we didn't we do recreate part of the the
bombing you know and that's we had 2,000
members of the Boston community working
as extras and many of them had been
there on Boylston Street when the bombs
went off and we recreate a big chunk we
built a piece of Boylston Street and
those those people came and were part of
the filming and as we said to that to
them members of basra and said this is a
part of the film the bombing recreation
is a part of the thumb but it is really
not about the entire film it's it's a
movie about heroism everyday people
rising up not and and refusing to lose
we'll take a break we'll come back Mark
Wahlberg will join us on the phone we'll
talk about this because I know it was
passionate for him and I'd like to know
what that first phone call was like when
Mark talked to you if that's the way it
went down on you know coming okay but
he's in a bad mood because the Giants
won and he somehow feels this is bad for
the Patriots so I just want to preface
the more the more of a hard time we give
him about that the more I would have
pretty with him last night as I was
flying on air Wahlberg you set the scene
for air Wahlberg what's that plane like
there Peter I don't want to out him but
let me say that it's it's smaller than a
747 it's bigger than a lot of regional
jets it's got about 15 televisions on it
and what the DirecTV and the pilots know
that we know whatever app there's
problems they change altitude very
quickly
it's dangerous ought to be you know in a
confined space of Mark when he's unhappy
about the result of football gam and he
tried to pretend that he didn't mind
that the judge having big giants that he
tried to pretend that he was okay with
the Giants winning and about the halfway
through the fourth quarter he just
snapped wait what'd he do
we started screaming yawning and
threatening and he just started
screaming this is it the jams will win
no more this is it and I don't even know
why he was home you beat him in the
Super Bowl twice of course a days
nervous that he was hoping that the
Patriots were gonna face the Cowboys and
now it's obvious that they're not headed
for a three-peat and I feel bad for him
and that poor guy he needs some good
luck here you know he's got no he's got
Markel join us to be a phone we're
talking to Peter Berg the movie is
patriots day limited release select
theaters December 21st then it's
released everywhere January 13th so
welcome back mark will join us here on
the Dan Patrick show story of a
community's extraordinary courage in the
face of adversity an account of the
events surrounding the 2013 Boston
Marathon bombing it chronicles in detail
one of the most sophisticated and well
coordinated manhunts in law enforcement
history Patriots day in select theaters
December 21st released everywhere
January 13th the brilliance behind the
movie Peter bird the director and Mark
Wahlberg who joins us via the phone
before we talk about the movie Pete says
you're in a bad mood mark are you no but
is there a jerk sitting on the set
wearing up New York Giants on this no
not right now
Oh a winner
but I don't want to upset you so I took
it off okay you know what it doesn't
have sent me other than the fact that I
didn't get any sleep and I'm tired and a
little rather do it in studios that's
not brotherly love what's gonna what are
you gonna be like if the Blackshirts
happen to lose tonight mark I'll be okay
we're gonna actually still be in the
Super Ball good morning wow did you get
it you know what Pete I love youse all
my heart embrace my heart that you have
all of a sudden with this nonsense
between us cuz you know what yesterday
we're brothers I'm bringing in my
hometown I'll show you what boss's song
is all about we make you an honorary
Bostonian which was one of the great
meetings of my of my life he gets almost
all we did was win and we beat the
Cowboys which is good for everybody I
told you you were gonna win you were us
day and I got mad when Eli fan then
threw the ball backwards by accident you
talk about guys jumping ship yeah oh my
god you know they turned over the bottom
the how many times this guy had nothing
but negative things to say about his
board he turned on them so quick he
started for the Eagles in the red
I never never never never I'll wait
dance and more important thing yesterday
my daughter was in trouble again oh my
god and we're in the elevator and all of
a sudden at the end of the day they had
to sit there watch Peter I do interviews
all day
one in each day opposite corner so he
couldn't talk to each other while we
were doing it and then she heard that I
was going to be on your show today and
she wanted to be on punishment again so
she could come back she was that she was
great last time we're talking to a Peter
Berg and Mark Wahlberg the movie is
patriots day it's released everywhere
January 13 I asked Peter the question
I'll ask you mark how nervous are you
about how this is received certainly in
Boston um you know it's one of those
things where obviously you know you wish
this whole thing just never happened he
was just a bad dream but people I have
so much pride and they responded in such
a strong and resilient way I think
people are ultimately going to be very
proud of certain people to relive the
worst day of their lives that is a
difficult thing but you know our goal
was to make people proud and to put a
face on all those people you know you
heard the stories in the news but you
didn't really get to know the people and
to see you know how proud I am in my
hometown and to share that with the
world knowing that deep things didn't
continue to happen out there but we can
come together we can we can get back up
and we can stand strong that's a very
important message and we need to get
that out there so I think it's gonna be
a very emotional thing but ultimately
that people to be extremely extremely
proud when they see the movie and how we
honored the people to Boston now I grew
up having a lot of a lot of sports
heroes you know
even though you know we didn't grow up
with a lot financially we had you know
to solve this Red Sox Bruins and the
Patriots to leave for and you know once
I saw this this this event people the
way they responded you know it redefined
the term zero for me you know people
from all walks of life men women from
anywhere you know coming together it was
it was
if there's a disagreement or if there's
a disagreement between you and Peter on
set how is that settled hmm you know
what with this the only time we ever had
and I would even say disagreements just
and I we just we had to make sure that
everything is right and coming down to
you know two words when people dialogue
hacks and all that stuff but um you know
we would just talk about it the great
thing about Pete and I in our
relationship you know we joke around
about Giants or the Patriots but you
know when it comes down to challenging
stories probably on people you know
we're not compromising we're getting it
right and we're there for each other and
we are like brothers in that way and we
can give each other crap like brothers
and you know I can't wait to steer today
and just give him a big hug and laughs
and you know I love is that gonna happen
people it'll definitely happen buddy I
mean I would say that you know I've
worked with mark three times now and
Mark always cares mark is the
hardest-working actor I've ever met gets
up earlier goes to bed later cares a lot
on this particular film because he
really is is the hometown boy and if the
favorite son of that City I think he
focused so intensely and really was a
great partner to me and was able to help
as a New Yorker Shepherd me through that
community in a way that I couldn't have
done without him so it's a great a great
friendship and a great partnership know
about that mark has my gift arrived yet
yeah is it in York Giants hummock
because I spin it here I got a Patriots
helmet and a Giants helmet in front of
me what I didn't know that there was a
gift coming here no I sent a gift via
email to DF overlock Oh two to two days
two days do you have an ID yet he's been
able to my lovely gift it has arrived
I'm sending it over to you right now oh
you are it's not a bottle of loppy Van
Winkle is it because that's what he
wants mark yeah yeah I heard you guys
were drinking Pappy Van Winkle last
night my last
you can come with us tonight yeah oh but
it's a close second where do we go
though what take our love oh boy yes
there's a picture of Peter dressed as
Bill Belichick wow you you're a walking
bad that Bill Belichick got his will cut
his teeth in New York learned how to
coach coaching for the New York Giants
as we pull up a picture the child is the
father of the man okay
the child of the father of Bill
Belichick is clearly the New York Giants
he's won one of my favorite coaches and
clearly learned the great majority of
his wisdom did you lose a bet no no no
I'm a big fan of Bill Belichick and you
just dressed like Bill Belichick well
not you should see the other picture I
had I had three I had three
Patriots with matta a friend dress up
his lady friend dress up his Tom Brady
Edelman and Gronkowski and I I was
always a team sort of a team effort I
did it to demonstrate my respect for for
Coach Belichick who's a great man and
and my good friend Mark Wahlberg but
coach Belichick was a giant long before
he was a patriot the movie why exactly
double check your system you lost a bet
no no I can hear him I can hear her I
can hear him not all I can hear him did
you lose a bet
not it Elizabet you know I'm a fan of
Bill Belichick and I think I'm concerned
cruising
sterling Shepard I mean I'm I am
honestly concerned yeah I remember all
the insults you would throw an adult
guys via the TV last night if if this
happens and the Patriots lose I'm
concerned for everybody so I I'm wishing
the Patriots are crazy that is you're
just a benevolent soul as what you are
Peter really it's remarkable this time
of the year
I like that terrible very so January
13th is Patriots Day mark good to
connect with yet we hope to be on walbro
is it air force bulbar pterois bear
wahlberg Oh air Wahlburgers arable
burger no Wahlberg air a little birds
Aaron it's a Wahlburgers with a French
accent Wahlberg and its Wahlberg I just
Pete want to change his name to Wahlberg
well we're changing our whole company to
wall you have am you change it to wall
so it's Peter Berger I was thinking
about of course we'll take the movies
I'll let you guys settle this later on
okay where they were lying on to lose to
make the playoffs I think the Giants
look good to make the plan look good
yeah they look good just take care of
business tonight mark don't be we're not
I don't I don't I don't pay attention to
that side of the fence you don't have to
worry Wow no I don't look down a look
over the fence
the movie is patrons day January 13th
everywhere
Peter Berg is the director and mark a
producer on the film also stars in the
movie as well great talk to you guys
tell your daughter we set a low mark and
we look forward to having her back on
with us
I will have to bring your next you know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna tell her if
you have good behavior the next time
then I'll bring her on there's no change
there is no chance your daughter is on
her best ears truly much on her face
when she couldn't come to see you guys
again was I think I think that was the
ground breaker I think I finally figured
out carrot dangled to actually keep her
you brokered right now good luck with
the movie guys thanks for joining us
we're back after this night the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]